a lot has changed in the open world
genre since the saints row series came
to its ridiculous conclusion amid an
alien invasion almost 10 years ago and
with the reboot of the franchise deep
silver volition seems to be taking a
look back at that time before open world
games were flooded with rpg inspired
elements and crafting systems the new
saints row feels a lot like a game from
a different era but with a bunch of
additions that make it more than just a
nostalgic return to the past these guys
won't freaking die
we played about four hours of saints row
at a recent preview event which
encompassed the beginning of the game as
with the original saints row the new
game is all about creating your own
criminal empire but you have a long way
to go before that happens it's set in
the new city of santo elaso a fictional
location in the united states southwest
that mixes an urban center suburbs and
desert locations and carries the vibe of
places such as las vegas or albuquerque
without being quite like either one
though we know you're eventually going
to become a crime kingpin the game
starts with your humble beginnings where
your character is living in a dingy
apartment with three friends mechanic
and driving wiz nina business expert eli
and shirtless dj and resident cook kev
everyone in the group is familiar with
petty crime and both nina and kev are
members of local gangs nina's with los
panteros a gang that's focused on cars
and weightlifting while kev hangs around
with the idols a band of techno
anarchists who believe in a
decentralized future you're a member of
the third gang in town and the only
semi-legitimate one a private military
corporation called martial defense
industries so at the start of saints row
your goal is to climb the corporate
ladder as a mercenary at marshall mostly
focused on bringing home enough rent
money to keep you and your friends from
eviction trying to find a way to pull
yourself up by your bootstraps and fight
an economic system stacked against you
is a pretty pervasive theme in saints
row at one point nina mentions the
driving force for her doing crimes at
all is to earn money to pay off her
student loans
your character is already a talented
killer full of bravado so the
opportunity to earn bonus pay for
performing well incentivizes you to
become a one-person maverick murder
machine
[ __ ]
take the turret i got it i'm good with
these the opening mission is your first
day with marshall dropping you and a
bunch of other soldiers into an
abandoned old west town filled with los
panteros gangsters guarding their boss
the mission highlights the lessons
saints row has taken from modern open
world games
it's a pretty cinematic event with
cutscenes popping up here and there as
you fight through waves of enemies and
advance on your objective
this approach gives those missions the
kind of storytelling gravitas you often
get out of more linear single-player
games and were reminiscent of what you
might see in the horizon games for
instance with a lot of emphasis placed
on characters and action driven scenes
in terms of gameplay however saints row
often feels like a throwback
the third person shooting aspect of the
game is pretty standard but i had a
really tough time getting used to the
feeling of aiming in saints row
the controller analog sticks were way
too sensitive with seemingly no way to
adjust them it took me a bit to get the
hang of how to hit targets which is best
done by making liberal use of the auto
aim assistance you get from aiming down
sights which magnetizes your reticle
onto a foe it reminded me of old school
open world shooting from the height of
saints row or the grand theft auto
series but not really in a good way
while the shooting itself is a bit
finicky saints row introduces cool
additions to gameplay that updated
overall
your health bar is divided into three
parts and while your health will
automatically recharge if you're out of
the line of fire for a few seconds it
won't refill fully so if you're between
one-third health and two-thirds health
you'll only recharge to the two-thirds
mark to get your health back fully you
have to kill enemies using spiffy
cinematic execution moves that you can
activate with a single button press when
you're close enough
the trouble is the execution ability
also charges over time so you can't
always pull one off
kills recharge the ability more quickly
so the more mayhem you create the more
executions you can pull off and the more
you can heal yourself it's a healing
system reminiscent of something like do
maternal encouraging you to constantly
mix it up in combat rather than hunker
down behind cover the first marshall
mission ends with you taking down the
bad guy against all odds including
stopping him from flying away in a jet
and fighting him on top of the plane
unfortunately disobeying orders and
taking matters into your own hands
doesn't earn you the acknowledgement or
bonus pay you'd hope for completing
missions earns you experience points
that play into a leveling progression
system the fruits of which make you more
of an overall badass leveling up takes
you along a linear progression path
unlocking either new equippable skills
or earning you passive upgrades like
boost to your overall health the skills
are the cool part as you can assign them
to certain buttons and use them in the
heat of battle the first one you unlock
allows you to grab a nearby enemy shove
a grenade down their pants and then
heave them back toward their friends and
it's incredibly useful for crowd control
the next main story mission your second
day on the job introduces some of saints
row's car combat elements sending you on
a mission to follow a panteros convoy
that quickly degrades into an all-out
battle of course cars are a big part of
saints row and you'll do a fair amount
of driving as well as shooting while
driving you can shoot out of the windows
when you're driving or riding in a car
but you're relegated to small guns and a
limited range of motion when you do so
to be more effective and deadly you can
climb on top of the car allowing you to
fire in all directions with bigger guns
but on the roof you have zero cover and
thus take a lot more damage from enemies
shooting back at you
after what feels like years of drive-by
shootings in games like this the ability
to climb in and out of cars to fight
during chases makes them much more
dynamic giving you some tactical options
and trade-offs to consider
by your third day on the job your
corporate overlords seem to have taken a
shine to you offering you a chance to
run security at a museum while a special
object called the codex is displayed the
other gangs show up to try to steal it
and despite the fact that you kill a
ridiculous number of them the codex is
ultimately swiped you're fired in
spectacular fashion despite heroic
efforts to save at least one life along
the way another reminder that the system
doesn't really care how hard you work
that codex also seems like it'll be an
important part to the story later on
although it's tough to see how at this
point
the best part of the story i've seen so
far is the dynamic between the main
characters the small group of friends
has an undeniable chemistry and their
commitment to one another provides the
drive to the story of founding the
saints they're fun interesting
characters and seeing how they develop
is as much a reason to keep playing as
shooting people and stealing cars as an
investor i don't like wasting money
you're wearing a [ __ ] bow tie
okay i will throw in 20 bucks for waffle
maker saints row also adopts something
of a different tone from the series past
it's much more grounded than the alien
invasion superhero story of saints row 4
but maintains major action comedy vibes
it's just more bad boys than the suicide
squad the whole thing is still extremely
over the top with plenty of headshots
and explosions this is certainly not a
serious game saints row puts its comedic
focus on its characters personalities
and on satirizing things like heartless
corporations and cryptocurrency
enthusiasts who want to destroy society
when you're not working on saints row's
main story there are plenty of other
side hustle missions popping up around
the world that allow you to earn more
money to buy guns cars and clothes for
later on these tend toward the goofy
side of the spectrum as well saints row
staples like insurance fraud make a
return in which you jump in front of
cars and otherwise injure yourself for
cash while other side hustles have you
flying in your new wingsuit or posting
really bad reviews about restaurants to
draw out and eliminate their killer
backers
there are also a ton of gameplay
challenges you can complete as you play
like driving in the oncoming traffic
lane for a certain amount of time or
killing a set number of enemies with
headshots and many of these earn you
special passive traits called perks that
you can equip to your character the perk
and leveling systems that unlock new
skills feel like another way volition is
merging the sort of old-school open
world chaos a game like saints row is
good at with more modern ideas of
character customization and creating
loadouts challenges are something you
complete while you're messing around in
the world or doing other missions but
the fact that you can change skills and
perks whenever you want means you're
encouraged to think strategically about
your abilities
the best part of saints row are the
combination of new ideas that play into
the strengths of this kind of open world
game where unpredictable fights with
gangs on the street or running from the
cops prove just as fun and rewarding as
the story though the game does suffer
some of the drawbacks of this style of
open world game like weird ai and weak
shooting a hearty helping of hilarious
unpredictability funny writing and
strong characters seem like they'll
provide lots of reasons to return to
saints row
you [ __ ] lied to us